French artist Francoise Gilot has made a
name for herself with her paintings but
it's two other names that have given her
an even greater notoriety she was a
longtime companion of Pablo Picasso and
later she was the wife of renowned
scientist dr. Jonas Salk as a couple
they traveled the world and now three of
her sketchbooks from those trips have
been published in a book by Taschen I
had the chance to speak with Francoise
Gilot
at her New York studio this book is
something that you find in Venice
Francoise g.low still has her sketchbook
from her trip to Venice in 1974 I always
have little books like that with me when
I travel she'd make observations
gondolas look like scorpions and record
her impressions of a city I love how you
convey water here mm-hmm
it's just great she'd been to Venice
with her parents as a child that's
France was and her mother there in 1937
you might say that they had I had Venice
in my veins
she was 53 when she made the trip again
with her husband the late dr. Jonas Salk
pioneer of the polio vaccine you are 97
now yes three more yell and I get to be
100 so so so are you excited at the
prospect of reaching a hundred it's a
bit unreal yeah even though it's in
stealth ok I cannot get used to the idea
but she's still painting and three of
her travel sketchbooks have just been
published together by passion at
Sotheby's in New York last month her
fans clamor to get signed copies when
did you know you wanted to be an artist
well you know that that is something
that is not necessarily willful from the
age of five I started drawing a lot like
for example I remember when I was at
school I was always drawing and that
used to exasperate my teachers
you're listening I said yes I'm
listening the the fact that I'm doing
doesn't prevent me from listening she
was 22 when she painted this
self-portrait in 1944 she had just met
Pablo Picasso in Paris the artist was 40
years older but they'd spend a decade
together until she became the only woman
ever to leave him as she told me in an
interview for CBS Sunday morning a few
years ago when I said I am here because
I love you but the day when I don't love
you I go mm-hmm ha ha ha
nobody leaves a man like me I said wait
and sing What did he say the day you
left the day I left he said ma'am
Jill Oh eventually found her way to New
York and as an artist earned her own
acclaim with Salk she traveled the world
to India in 1979 Jonas and myself had
gone through India for Christmas she was
fascinated by the saris as a kind of
spiral the saris are a unique mystery
she wrote she went to Senegal in 1981
and that's a Bay and people sell their
wares on the under beach in the
sketchbooks you're not really trying to
copy what you see no because then I will
be better off with a camera I noticed
what I feel JLo says not what is there
most of the time I was drawing them when
I was in a plane were you drawing these
from memory then I always work from
memory I'm not somebody who is good at
working from nature you're not
responsible to reality no because
reality is always contradicting me we
all have that type of experience yeah
that realities just say to endow you and
to limit this no it's not exactly like
that
you know Zillow still works every day
and at 97 thinks about hitting that
century mark
it's an imposing number yes 100 and then
after that you say well if I got there
you know
not a bit more she is just an amazing
woman absolutely love her know what the
difference between ten years with the
sock was like oh my gosh